les murs et les façades de l'institut
médico éducatif de la montagne sont
peuplées d'étranges animaux colorés
depuis six mois
cet établissement qui accueille des
jeunes déficients psychique a proposé à
l'artiste graffeur guan une résidence il
peint et expose ses oeuvres qui seront
un déplaçables elle reconfigurer
l'univers des locaux de l'établissement
accueillir un artiste en résidence et
lui donner carte blanche
c'est aussi permettre une rencontre avec
les jeunes de l'institut médico-éducatif
parmi les oeuvres de gorgan il en est
une à laquelle tous les jeunes
participent se penser à les faire
travailler sur un buzz
j'ai encore puis smos est à plat
tranquillement sur des morceaux de bois
et après on reconstituera se paye sur le
mur alors on est parti sur le rêve sur
l'évasion donc un rêve qui nous permet
de nous évader facilement n'importe qui
on est peu importe où on est voilà ses
rêves permet nous évader est parti sur
l'oiseau qui représente quand même assez
facilement la liberté que j'ai des
limites et avec différentes zones qui
représentent chaque couleur et chacune
de ces zones est attribué à un des
résidents après chaque résidant à
travailler en amont sont maigres et donc
après la fin alors que il redessine
serait sur son morceau voir s'ils sont
en train de faire aujourd'hui
après ils vont le peindre et après une
fois que toutes ses rêves du pain on va
aller on voulait rassembler et des fixé
sur le mur sur lequel grille-pain
d'autres oiseaux
au reste des droits pourrait vraiment un
cv rookie de la menti
aujourd'hui c'est mieux dissimuler
le perroquet les maisons les branches
c'est sur ce mur de 15 mètres de haut
que les travaux des jeunes seront fixés
chacun a peint son rêve
il est temps de commencer à fixer les
parties de cet oiseau pour les jeunes
qui ont participé
c'est une fierté des saletés louis c'est
leur rêve ateliers ici ça a super beau
c'est pas toujours vois ça c'est
chouette
oui ça va plus basse et bien dessinés
avec la présence de dessinateur ça me
fait chaud au coeur et ça me fait
plaisir et ça me fait super g super
content
et voilà j'aime bien ce projet collectif
a bien sûr des vertus éducatives au
point que l'éducatif c'est beaucoup de
valorisation pour la confiance en eux
aussi parce qu'on a beaucoup qui va qui
doute de beaucoup de même qu'ils se
sentent rabaissé et donc c'est d'avoir
une grosse mise en valeur pour leurs
familles pour les amis pour l'extérieur
parce qu'ils sont amenés à passer à la
télé où il ya des invités qui viennent
ici au vernissage de la semaine
prochaine il y aura beaucoup de
personnes que eux ne connaissent pas qui
vont ils viennent nous voir leur travail
à eux ils sont fiers sacs sont pressés
d'aller voir pour montrer ce que eux ont
fait le potentiel de développement
personnel que déploient les activités
artistiques l'établissement en a fait le
coeur de son projet c'est à dire que
nous avons dans le cadre de notre projet
d'établissement
on a souhaité vraiment développer toute
la dimension autour de l'art et de la
culture
est-ce que son s'est rendu compte
effectivement que c'était très important
pour ces jeunes déficients d'avoir aussi
accès à 7 à cette possibilité là ce qui
n'est pas forcément le cas dans leur vie
de tous les jours selon eux l'art aide à
trouver sa place dans la société
l'art permet effectivement de
de trouver sa place dans la société
dans la mesure où vous allez pouvoir
vous exprimer vous exprimer rencontrer
d'autres personnes être comme tout le
monde et je pense que ça c'était très
important il n'y a pas de différence
comme disait bourdieu c'est la
différence aux différents ce qui fait la
différence donc c'est très intéressant
si vous voulez de pouvoir gommer
l'ensemble ces différences même si au
fond de soi on sait que on est en
situation de handicap
l'artiste a continué jusqu'à la nuit
tombée pour fixer l'intégralité de
l'oeuvre qui signe également la fin de
sa résidence
encore quelques retouches et l'oiseau
pourra s'envoler
oh et